as a little bit of a review we know that
if we have some function let's call it f
we don't have to call it f but f is the
letter most typically used for functions
then if I give it an input a valid input
if I give it a valid input and I use the
variable X for that valid input it is
going to map that to an output it is
going to map that or produce given this
X it's going to produce an output that
we would call f of X and we've already
talked a little bit about the notion of
a domain a domain is the set of all of
the inputs over which the function is
defined so this is the domain here if
this is the domain here and I take a
value here and I put that in for X then
the function is going to output an f of
X if I take something that's outside of
the domain within a different color if I
take something that is outside of the
domain and try to input it into this
function the function will say wait wait
I'm not defined for that thing that's
outside of the domain now another
interesting thing about another
interesting thing to think about and
that's actually what the focus of this
video is okay we we know the set of all
the valid inputs that's called the
domain but what about all the set of all
of the outputs that the function could
actually produce and we have a name for
that that is called the range of the
function
so the range the range and the most
typical there's actually a couple of
definitions for range but the most
typical definition for range is the set
of all possible outputs so you give me
you input something from the domain it's
going to output something and by
definition because we've outputted it
from this function that that thing is
going to be in the range and if we take
the set of all of the things that the
function could output that is going to
make up the range so this right over
here is the set of all possible all
possible outputs all possible outputs so
let's make that a little bit more
concrete with an example so let's say
that I have the function f of X defined
as so once again I'm going to input X's
and I have my function f and I'm going
to output f of X and let's say the stuff
in the function definition here the
thing that tries to figure out okay give
it an X what f of X do I produce the
definition says f of X is going to be
equal to whatever my input is squared
well this is a little bit of review we
know what the domain here is going to be
the domain is a set of all valid inputs
so what are the valid inputs here well I
can take any real number and input into
this and then I take any real number and
I can square it there's nothing wrong
with that and so the domain is all real
numbers all all real all real numbers
but what's the range let me I'll do that
in a different color just to highlight
it what is going to be the range here
what is the set of all possible outputs
well if you think about it actually to
help us think about it let me actually
draw a graph here of what this looks
like what this looks like so the graph
of f of X is equal to x squared is going
to look something like this
so it's going to look it's going to look
something like this I'm obviously hand
drawing it so it's not perfect it's
going to be a parabola with a with a
vertex right here at the origin so this
is the graph this is the graph y is
equal to f of X this of course is the
x-axis this of course is the y-axis so
let's think about it what is the set of
all possible outputs in this case the
set of all possible outputs is the set
of all possible y's here well we see Y
can take on any non-negative value Y
could be 0 Y could be 1 Y could be PI Y
could be e but Y cannot be negative so
the range here is the range we could
well we could say it a couple of ways we
could say f of X let me write it this
way f of X is a member of the real
numbers such that is such that f of X is
greater than or equal to zero we could
write it that way if we wanted to write
it in less Matthieu notation we could
say that f of X f of X is going to be
greater
then or equal to zero f of X is not
going to be negative so any non-negative
number that the set of all non-negative
numbers that is our range let's do
another example of this just to make it
a little bit just to make it a little
bit a little bit clearer let's say that
I had let's say that I had G of X let's
say I have G of X I'll do this in white
let's say it's equal to x squared over X
so we could try to simplify G of X a
little bit we could say look if I have x
squared and divided by X that's going to
that's the same thing as G of X being
equal to X x squared over X is X but we
have to be careful because right over
here we have two in our domain X cannot
be equal to zero if X is equal to 0 we
get 0 over 0 we get indeterminate form
so in order for this function to be the
exact same function we have to put that
because it's not obvious now from the
from the from the definition we have to
say X cannot be equal to 0 so G of X is
equal to X for any X as long as X is not
equal to 0 these two function
definitions are equivalent and we could
even graph it we could graph it it's
going to look I'm going to do a quick
and dirty version of this graph it's
going to look something like this it's
going to be it's going to have a slope
of 1 it's going to have a hole right at
0 because it's not defined at 0 so it's
going to look like this so the domain
here the domain of G is going to be X is
a member of the real numbers such that X
does not equal 0 and the range is
actually going to be the same thing the
range here is going to be we could say f
of X is a member of the real numbers
such that f of X does not equal 0 f of X
does not equal 0 so the domain is all
real numbers except for 0 the range is
all real numbers except for 0 so the big
takeaway here is the range is all the
positive set of all possible outputs of
your function the domain is a set of
all valid inputs into your function